Dr Amanda fader with Johns Hopkins
medicine says the cancer drug shortage
in the United States amounts to a Public
Health crisis it's devastating as an
oncologist we we live to help our
patients live longer better lives and so
not having the tools at our disposable
that we know can help our patients
achieve this is is terrible cisplatin is
credited as the drug that changed cancer
treatment 50 years ago skyrocketing The
Cure rate of testicular cancer and also
effective against lung breast and
ovarian cancers in June 70 percent of
U.S Cancer Centers said they were short
on the drug and 93 percent said they
were short on the related drug
carboplatin it is the drug there isn't
anything that works as effectively
it is the drug I need
41 year old Carrie cherkinski has stage
three ovarian cancer but she hasn't
received carboplatin due to the shortage
these are very cheap drugs and and
manufacturers are not really
incentivized to create quality drugs in
this scenario because they're not
getting a lot of profit from
manufacturing these drugs at just
dollars per dose drug makers largely
rely on cheaper Manufacturing in China
and India so when a factory in India had
to Halt production of carboplatin in
November due to Quality concerns the
global Supply quickly dwindled our
continued over-reliance on foreign
suppliers for the key materials needed
to make critical drugs primarily those
in China remain an unacceptable National
Security risk
the U.S is allowing the temporary import
of cisplatinum from China at least until
the shortage improves but everyday drugs
including children's pain medicines have
also experienced recent shortages due to
similar supply chain problems both
parties in Congress have introduced
measures that would broaden regulations
and incentivize drug makers to increase
production but those solutions would
take time
meanwhile patients and doctors say time
is the enemy when life-saving treatments
are needed now and they urge the
government to declare a public health
emergency
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington